so Cathy oh no yeah I'm gonna pick on
you let's see so of the Dombrowski clan
of the women in that family Nana was
definitely the peanut butter to the
Wonder Bread in my opinion I am
definitely the N and the PB&J yeah love
Nana huh yeah so what did you see when
you read the script the first time when
Jeremy first sent me the script these
guys old you know really paid their dues
and went up to the Sundance labs and she
sat in my closet for two years trying to
rap I said Danielle can you think oh no
no I don't think so
they put in so much time but I had the
privilege of working with Jeremy
previously on his first short that he
directed and wrote and so we went down
to Mexico and hadn't met him yet and
they kind of just sit back and when I
got to the set he was directing this
circus and I literally mean a circus not
with elephants but like a circus and and
I just watched him and just visually he
in and what he sent me on that short is
what got me on a plane because I have a
tendency you know to be lazy so I don't
like doing things I just like staying
home so I just watched him cinematically
visually his camera movements and what
he wanted and how precise he was and he
kept looking at me while we were doing
like other scenes and stuff and it's
like what's up with you
you're perfect for this role I'm writing
it was like okay kids and um then he
said he called me it was almost to the
year he said Kathy I'm done with the
script can I send it to you I said
that's a good idea
then I can read it and I read it can I
read it again then I had to go back and
I had to read it again because every now
and then you come across something that
you know that just hits you a certain
way and for me this hit me a certain way
the dynamic between the three women in
the movie the loss that everybody has
gone through the dynamic the underdog
and and I just I fell madly in love with
it and when he called me up did you like
it and I told him no and there was just
silence I said I loved it and um he said
well will you do it I said I'll do
anything for you Jeremy I said but this
one I have to do he said I can't pay you
I said what else is new and um that was
it you know they went to Kmart got me a
sweat suit and a little gray wig and in
a wheelchair in a wheelchair not a very
good one I might add nothing but the
best for you apparently but the best for
Nana but it was a privilege and an honor
doing this movie because it's dynamic I
mean never met anybody Bridget Everett
who is just the supreme powerhouse so I
kind of privately stalked
please barb Mamadou who is mr. Yale mr.
Method Man Sid who's just ok I'll try it
you please Jerry and when I first met
Danielle she walked in and I saw her
face I was like that's Nana's superstar
that's it we got a home run yeah that's
for sure well giving him the know that's
very Nana that's sassy that's I could
hear her doing that alright well
Danielle I'm gonna go on a limb and
guess that every interview you've done
about this film somehow touches on the
fact that you're not exactly from New
Jersey but I think that that is because
it is noteworthy and impressive and
worthy of discussion because I I just
can't believe there's a casting director
out there that when approached to cast
this role that their response would be
let me see who I can get from Australia
to do this that would be perfect so what
in your life and your career thus far
gave you the steam to be Patty I don't
know actually I don't a casting director
didn't recognize this was um what about
produces had see me in the first film
that I'd ever done and he put my photo
in from in front of Jeremy and Jeremy
said that's what I've been picturing for
15
is when I pictured this character but he
had no idea I was Australian and could
not rap at all so that was kind of an
issue and I've read the script and I I
loved I started laughing like full pages
in because she's on stage rapping and
she's cool I can't do this but I I spoke
to him on the phone and we talked about
it and I said you know I love this
script and I really really want to do it
but I can't rap and I don't know Jesse
and I I'm not cool and this is I might
fail and he just kind of had this belief
of me which says so much to him he has
great instincts and I felt safe and
trusted him from a phone call so he went
to the Sundance directors lab we
workshop five scenes and by the end of
it we're like we're doing this and we
didn't have funding or anything but I
practiced a rap a week in my closet
hoping that maybe one day this movie
would get made and it did almost two
years later sir yeah well look how far
you've come
it must have been quite a workout going
from no wrapping to what we saw tonight
oh yeah it took a while for me to
understand what breath control was not
musical at all and I just I mean I had a
whole system that I made up like with
like little lines and dot's so that I
could know when to breathe and I tried
all these different rap is like just
songs of this and would send them to
Jeremy and sometimes he's like that's
really bad I would try again he's like
let's move on to the next one so we
figured out what was good what was bad
there was a lot of failure but there was
also a lot of effort that was the one
thing we just kind of he never gave up
on me and I never gave up on this and we
just figured it out I guess this is I
understand it pretty much almost like a
biopic of you you grew up in Jersey
taking care of an aging grandparent I
did you started writing rap when you
were about nine drew jonesing to get out
of Jersey yep so when it came to I'm
gonna put this story down I'm gonna tell
this story why did you choose to make
your your lead a young lady instead of
for example a young man like yourself
the the idea for the film started with
the character way before it was gonna be
oh this is I'm gonna channel my
experiences into this film that came
later the the the idea of patty Patricia
Dombrowski from around where I grew up
in New Jersey kind of striving to be a
rapper it just popped into my brain when
I was 23 and living living in Jersey
working a crappy catering job I was
driving around with my friend and we
were this in the hot 97 like we did and
you just all you do is drive around in
New Jersey there was nothing to do and I
just it just popped into my head
you know I came from a family of these
women and there was something about that
attitude that bravado that like no shame
in their game they had they were very
there was a sense of pride and and
toughness that seemed to click with what
a great MC would be you know there's
there's no there's no apologies you know
it's you know my mom is a big woman who
wears sweat suits and you know has never
gone jogging in her life and she's cool
with that
so it just seemed to be it just clicked
to me and I just stored away the idea
for the character in the back of my
brain and then you know 15 years later I
kind of challenged myself to write my
first screenplay okay and it was well
write about what you know and I had been
a musician for many years I was in a
band I had toured I had spent years and
years in the studio I had written tons
of songs you know filled notebooks with
songs if no one would it whatever here
just like Patti and I don't know it just
you just started thinking about where
you grew up and where you where you what
you've become and and all your dreams
back then and it just kind of clicked
with this character so then we're off to
the races
I was not interested in telling some
young man's story it was you know it's
like a love letter to the women that
raised me and like that was that was
important